about yourselves so raise your hand I
guess if you're from Wellesley nobody at
lawlessly wants to fly okay
Harvard okay
everybody else can boo who's not who has
no MIT affiliation all right awesome
well welcome who actually raise your
hand if you've never been in a light
aircraft if you have no experience in a
little airplane okay that's good that's
a good number for the for the MIT folks
how many are you how many of you are
undergrads okay that's a good number how
many of you are graduate students even
larger number and how many of you are
neither you're just like an MIT alum or
staff just a few okay great well welcome
all of you and let's just go through the
goals let's see what who's in the room
who wants to eventually fly an airplane
whoa how about a helicopter good I'm
happy to see that what about drones
alright that's a larger number than last
year that's great all right so your
course objectives are to get ready for
your official FAA knowledge test this is
sometimes called the written test as
opposed to the practical test or the
check ride that you do at the end of
your flight training it's available in a
bunch of different versions including
for airplanes and helicopters we're
going to concentrate in this class on
airplane partly because of the show of
hands
you will also be prepared though for the
FAs remote pilot test if you decide to
go direct entry into the world of
commercial drones we hope that this is
also going to help you any kind of
thorough study usually helps you make
more efficient use of your in aircraft
time and because we have tina here with
her PhD and aero-astro we're going
learn something about the engineering as
well so what is great about aviation you
know people were dreaming about flying a
long time ago going back to the ancient
Greeks only recently we've been able to
do it which is a good thing one thing I
like about it is to look at the geology
and the organization of human settlement
on the planet it's there's a lot of
interesting structural patterns that one
can see from above flying you know a lot
of the greatest engineering achievements
of the last hundred years or so are
embodied in the aircraft that you know
you can personally go down to the local
airport rent and fly also you know I
mind everybody at MIT is pretty good at
doing stuff at a desk and thinking about
hard problems when sitting at a desk but
there's no emotions to manage a lot of
other than depression
so you know flying combines everything
you might be a little bit afraid it's
not natural to be up in the air so
you're working all of your human
capacities at one time you're managing
your fear you're working your brain to
think about what's coming next
and you're also working your muscles
finally you know you can get to the
beach quickly but as I note here you
know most places unfortunately little
airplanes when you factor in the weather
and all the training that you have to do
a lot of times you could have gotten
door to door faster I might I might also
just ask a couple of you guys pretty
much everyone raised their hand about
wanting to fly so maybe we can just get
here from a couple of you why do you
want to fly what's your interest in
taking the course
now like five tears already dead and if
it's a normal step to like
that's great so just for the folks that
couldn't hear oh and what's your name
Lawrence Lawrence was saying he's a PhD
student in aerospace engineering and has
learned all the theory and so it's a
natural step to want to go and do it
yourself that's great all right can you
do it yes as in fact appears on the
slide here there are a whole bunch of
little airports near us we'll show them
on a subsequent slide they all have
flight schools and you can rent either
airplanes or helicopters or both as well
as find an instructor to teach you you
can actually learn to fly in about ten
hours to me it's a little bit
unfortunate that so much emphasis is
placed on getting a pilot certificate
because it is an independent achievement
to actually be able to take off cruise
around and land without the instructor
having to touch anything
so that achievement unfortunately isn't
recognized with a little certificate but
that's actually learning to fly the rest
of the training which you know takes
three times as long as actually learning
the fly is directed at flying a broken
aircraft or a lost aircraft all this
stuff that prepares you to be the only
pilot in the aircraft which may not even
be a goal for passengers they would
rather have two pilots in the front not
just one pilot but there's a bizarre
focus on training one person to do
everything which we'll get into a little
bit more okay so here's our local area
and watch this fancy device here whoa
so we're somewhere between Logan Airport
on the bottom right and Hanscom field
which is surrounded by dashed blue line
telling you it's a towered Airport so
those are the two closest airports I
think Norwood is just about as close
I'll show that right here on the lower
left of the figure these airports that
are
in a magenta color those don't have
control towers over here is Beverly and
here's Lawrence I think we've covered
the airports that MIT folks most
normally fly out of but there's also
Nashua not too far away so their Airport
you're surrounded by airports even if
Logan is the one that you're most
familiar with Hanscom field is the most
substantial of the airports this is only
about a third of the ramp space and
hangars and structures built up around
Hanscom that's a picture that I took
from Robinson r44 helicopter which you
guys could be flying in next week and he
was gonna tell you what she likes to do
on a typical trip so we heard from a
couple of you that are observers or
participants in the MIT flying club did
anyone participate in the fly out a
couple years ago to Maine to Bar Harbor
all right so this is a picture from that
flight to Bar Harbor just grab the
clicker for me Thanks so if you were to
drive you know we took off just as
Phillip was describing one of the nearby
airports is at Hanscom so we we took off
from Hanscom if you were to drive it
would be a four and a half hour drive to
get there and back so it wouldn't really
be something that you could easily do as
a day trip but since we're flying it was
a great day trip so we flew up along the
coast all the way to Bar Harbor and what
was really great about that is that we
could go hiking so this was the all
these folks flew in little airplanes
from the Boston area through the MIT
flying Club and we all flew up to Bar
Harbor Maine and then we went hiking in
the Acadia woods and forests it was
really beautiful wonderful day and then
we flew back and landed just after
sunset back here so it was a really
beautiful experience and a lot of fun to
fly along the coastline so I highly
recommend it
if you're looking for a longer trip so I
designed this you can check it out on my
web blog it is a trip in a little Cirrus
that'll take you to all 48 states in
just 18 days and only about 50 hours of
flight time and that's a pretty standard
a little airplane but more importantly
so people who I just came back from
Bentonville Arkansas and there's a guy
there who's the grandson of Sam Walton
the founder of Walmart so he can pretty
much do anything he wants and what does
he like to do he has a couple p-51
Mustangs he was flying alongside this
little Dean Verde aerobatic plane that
we were testing out he's got a super
corsair there were only ten built he
started as a little of a flight school
at the local airport he flies his whole
phenom 300 business JAL over the world
so you know I think that's a proof that
flying is fun because people who could
do anything that they want to do also
fly you're going to meet people from all
around the world of all different ages
it's a very diverse group especially if
you like older guys
which I do
is it safe okay so we're gonna show you
how to make it safe it's not safe
statistically compared to JetBlue but
that's not because little airplanes are
feeble as you'll see in this class I
think it's because of the way that
people have been flying them so we're
going to show you how if you train like
the airlines and fly like the airlines
you can be getting much closer to
airline level of safety in little
airplanes as long as you're a little bit
conservative with the weather and if all
else fails if you're flying a modern
design airplane reach up and pull the
parachute and the whole airplane will
float down and you'll get out into a
swamp okay so this is me I was class of
82 at MIT it was much more challenging
then than it is for you guys that's
because the Wisconsin Ice Sheet was
covering the campus to a depth of about
a hundred and feet so we had to tunnel
our way from East Campus into the main
buildings I've been flying since 2002
I'm an instructor at East Coast Aero
Club at Hanscom field I was also a
regional jet pilot I decided to learn to
fly jets and there's no better way to do
that than at the airline's so I flew a
50-seat regional jet called the CRJ
Canada regional jet for Delta I have
type ratings which we'll get into later
you need specific licensing for each
turbojet powered aircraft that you fly
so I've got two of those for one of
them's for the smallest Cessna business
jet I usually fly though these days a
four-seat Cirrus Robinson r44 a
four-seat helicopter and a Pilatus pc-12
which holds either 11 people total or 60
sea turtles which we'll get into a
little bit later
so this is a little bit about me in the
top left corner you'll see me I'm
actually sitting in a Cessna 172 here at
Hanscom and I'm doing my engine run-up
and what do you see out the at the
window does anyone recognize it an f-18
so so what's really cool is that this
Airport that I fly out of Hanscom is
also a military Air Force Base which is
really exciting because upon occasion
you'll actually see military jets come
out and they of course did not wait for
me even though I was first in line they
night they nicely cut in front there
they called themselves jet one and jet
two and they went out and it really
looked like they didn't take any space
at all to any of the runway length to
takeoff it really looked from where I
was sitting kind of right next to it
like they like they just turned like a
rocket ship and took off and it was it
was really amazing it's hard yet no
problem so this is just a picture of me
just going on a flight with some other
MIT folks in the area and then of course
if all else fails you can just jump out
so a little bit of background so I'm I'm
also aero-astro just like you Lawrence
and so I I studied course 16 here I did
my undergrad in 2009 and I was really
passionate about it and continued on and
I did the MIT system design and
management program for my master's
degree and then continued on in an
interdepartmental PhD across aero-astro
engineering systems and Sloan it's a
really great experience one of the
things that got me really excited about
it is that when I was an undergrad in
the core 16 department we were
developing a satellite and we needed to
test that satellite so we actually got
to go on a zero gravity flight so I
don't know has anyone heard of a
zero-gravity flight or the vomit comment
alright so a couple folks didn't raise
their hands so the idea is that
the plane flies in a parabolic
trajectory and much like a rollercoaster
when you're at the top of the parabola
or the top of the roller coaster you
know how your stomach feels like it's
lifting all right we're getting some
head nods the rest of you guys really
need to go on a roller coaster
so when you get that you can actually
when an airplane flies like that you can
have everyone inside the airplane kind
of float up and have that sensation of
zero gravity or microgravity it lasts
about 30 seconds and that's also how
they film certain movies like Apollo 13
to show the astronauts and
weightlessness so we use that to test
our satellite so it was a really great
experience it got me really excited
about things and then I felt very
similar to you that I wanted to see the
theory in action and so I became a pilot
in terms of my professional career I
developed electronic warfare systems I
went on to Raytheon I was the chief
engineer of a 40 million dollar advanced
radar and electronic warfare system now
I'm into entrepreneurship and have my
own company in the security space and
I've been a pilot since 2012 and I love
flying with the MIT flying Club and I'm
currently working on my IFR who knows
what if' R stands for shout it out
good job instrument flight ratings if
you don't know that's fine we're gonna
cover that so we'll explain it all but
right now I fly a pretty much usually
the training aircraft the Cessna 172
it's a very very safe and stable
aircraft so we'll talk about a bunch of
different aircraft all right so let's
hope that you've done the pre-reading if
you hadn't you know I know everybody
here in this room at least the MIT and
Harvard folks are good at the book stuff
so please do hit the books some of the
thorny R and less interesting topics
we're going to rely on you to read
through the book so don't worry if you
get everything in the class we're giving
you kind of the highlights that are in
the books and passing is 70 on the test
all right optional supplies just for
your reference if you you know study a
typical flight student a lot of them
will have
a non fa textbook it's not necessary but
some people like the different
perspective there's a free online one
that we reference later that's written
by a PhD physicist which is kind of
interesting a lot of people have a hard
copy a big thick book called far aim
with the regulations and the FAS overall
guidance on how to use airports and
electronic navigation there are test
preparation books that you can get an
electronic versions of this that just
give you sample tests you're going to
use one of the websites from the king
schools
it's a popular vendor for those and then
before your checkride you'll be reading
the airman certification standards FAA
still is this kind of sexist language
there's air man and airman for all
pilots and this is tells you what you
need to demonstrate when you're getting
your final chapter most people will also
buy their own personal headset the noise
canceling ones make life a lot better
Lightspeed it's probably a little more
rugged than Bose Bose is more
comfortable on the years the front desk
of a typical flight school will have all
this stuff for sale the process a lot of
people who wonder well how do I get to
my private pilot's license you need the
flight training you apply for a student
pilot certificate on an FAA website I
don't know if that's still running
completely I just renewed the
registration for an aircraft so that
part of the FAA is running I don't know
if they're sending out student pilot
certificates during the shutdown or not
you have to do one medical exam in your
life at least with an aviation doctor
who's been blessed by the FAA and you
get your third class medical after
eventually you'll be able to go your
regular doctor if you want then you take
this knowledge test and that's what
you're being prepped for in this class
and finally you'll do your practical
exam with an FAA designated examiner one
of whom should actually be here tomorrow
so you can ask him how he tortures
people on the checkride I actually I had
to take one you have to do you know a
lot of these steps over again when you
do a type rating for a new aircraft so
when I worked at the airline the oral
there was a guy who was famously harsh
and he would keep people who are trying
to fly the Canada regional jet in knots
for hours and have him sweating during
the oral exam and the first question he
asked me the airplane has these
hydraulic pumps that they're AC motors
and it has the engines generating the AC
power but a lot of stuff runs on DC and
I'd really wondered about the electrical
systems of the airplane so I called up a
friend of mine as a physics professor at
UC Berkeley and we had a one-hour
discussion about when it made sense to
generate AC and pipe that around the
airplane and high voltage versus low
voltage in DC and so I hung up and said
goodbye to my friend Joel and then a few
weeks later there was the oral exam and
and the first question the guy asked me
was and my resume I'd put on my resume
that I just had a bachelor's degree I
didn't list any of my other degrees I
have a PhD in EE as it happens so this
guy who was the the bane of all the
pilots at this Delta subsidiary
he said Philip what why does the
airplane have both an AC and a DC system
so I gave him a little five-minute spiel
based on my conversation with my physics
professor friend he said okay the oral
dough rolls over it's time to go into
the simulator it maps me another a
single other question all right so let's
do the part that we should have done it
earlier put on the mic so it's
conventional in religious settings to
bring in a reformed sinner
and that's what we have here somebody
who's found faith and there's now living
the name thank you so much for lip and
Dina for having me here I mean actually
I'm a fourth-year PhD student at Harvard
I do neuroscience and when I'm not
trying to understand how the brain works
I like to do most things adventurous and
I had really awesome friends who
introduced me to the MIT Flying Club so
that was my first general aviation
experience I was a passenger on a fly
out to Republic Airport it's in Long
Island it's really nice because most of
the times if we get cleared we get to
fly over the Hudson and you'll get this
really nice view of the New York skyline
so and I so the the other photo is
actually Philip and his sitter so I was
super lucky to be on an other fly out as
a passenger and I got to fly in his in
the sitarist so this is to Chatham
another really beautiful airport in the
Cape Cod so all of that inspired me to
become a pilot but what really enabled
me was precisely this course because so
I am doing my PhD in neuroscience my
aviation knowledge was literally like
like Calvin was like okay there are all
these little button styles probably just
had to check all those things and just
like magic that civilians are flying so
I like this course was what really laid
the foundation for the aviation
experience in the rest of my life
and Tina was one of the instructors when
I took the course it was a slightly
different format it was over the entire
semester once a week but I really
enjoyed it so the end of it I felt
really ready to take the practical
flying lesson so I was a student pilot
at East Coast Aero Club Bedford so my
two years of grad school stipend that I
saved was like put to good use and the
picture on the left is my first solo so
that's though that's me doing the
traffic pattern at Bedford so like I
didn't have any like fancy electronic
flight back then I was just all paper
mouths so there was
the GPS on my phone tracking me doing
the traffic partnered Bedford and like
you can see how happy I was with all my
cell phone
Smiley's my logbook so then think end of
September got my private pilot's license
so I flew the warrior so yeah so that's
the that's me after the check ride after
passing the check ride in the warrior
so after ppl I wanted too much to take
spin training and did a little bit of
aerobatics in the decathlon at East
Coast so decathlon's orb is a tailwheel
aerobatic aircraft and i and when when
you do your PPO they're always going to
tell you like you you will do stalls and
they're always going to tell you that
like okay and we don't want to spin that
was like okay I wanna for you how it is
going yeah oh sorry yeah ppl is privates
pilot's license which is what all of us
here for so yeah so after so after a
little bit of aerobatic and it's been
training so my recent flying experience
is being a lot with MIT flying club now
as a pilot so this so I did the same the
first time I was ever on the light
aircraft which was this layout with the
ready flying club to Republic Airport
and and very recently I did that as a
pilot carrying like passengers with the
flying club so that felt really nice so
you can you can see like over the Hudson
mm feel southbound towards Republic and
you get this really awesome view of the
New York skyline and yeah it's it's
really beautiful if you get it talk to
like LaGuardia Newark and I spoke to
Carol tower that was like literally a
dream come true for me so I would relive
this moment like any number of times I'm
500 feet above the ground level and like
you can see the tiny shadow of my
aircraft and like talking to JFK and I'm
500 feet because there are all these
commercial jets deciding to land at JFK
so it's it's a totally beautiful feeling
so I've also been flying with my friends
and like this is
though Winnipesaukee lake near Laconia
yeah I'm sure
and yeah for the Howard folks things
just one person you can probably
recognize like Sanders theater so this
is a city tour so you could get cleared
into the Boston class bravo airspace and
so you can yeah this is one of my
friends who took photo of like though
yeah
the Howard campus you can see Sanders
Theater of a Memorial Church and just
fall setting in so my mom visited me
from Indy I took her flying so that was
a very beautiful feeling like to show
her what this means to me although she
was totally terrified yeah so I guess
okay so obviously I love it I mean it's
really fun the beautiful view is
experience and like the super adrenaline
and excitement every time I have the
play in and and this it is challenging
and there's really something like new
rewarding to learn from every single
experience every single flight and of
course the people so yeah thank you and
just just sharing my experience from
like having no errors to background to
being here I hope it inspires some of
you
[Applause]
we're coming back and sharing your
experience so so that could be could be
you guys next year so a little bit about
the FAA written exam so as we said
sometimes it's called the written that
is the knowledge based exam so that is
what ideally you'll be prepared to pass
with flying colors so it's a
computer-based multiple-choice exam they
usually give you about two and a half
hours and you don't necessarily need the
whole time there are 60 questions and
they basically kind of shuffle those
questions so we're gonna be teaching
content somewhat that goes beyond this
exam because this is an MIT course so
we're actually going to teach a little
bit more about the aerodynamics and and
how really planes fly and go a little
bit beyond just the course but we will
cover all this material and then so as
as Philip Artie said to pass you need a
70 but we believe that you can you can
score higher than that so we really
encourage you to take this exam right
after the course so we can actually
Philip can actually endorse your logbook
or you can we you can actually print out
a logbook and endorse you to take that
written exam so just following the
course the final exam of this course
will be a practice FAA exam and so you
can take that you can actually take it
as many times as you want in order to
pass but hopefully you don't have to
take it too many times and after that
will endorse you so that you can
actually go take the actual FAA written
exam and get that out of the way so you
can be on your way to becoming a pilot
okay so most East Coast Aero Club I'm an
instructor they are most of the people
that I've seen will skim through at
least the FAA books about three times
before they take the test they will use
a test prep book and they end up getting
you know a 98 or 100 on the exam so they
do a little bit they go a little bit
overboard if the goal is just to pass
again if you have the physics question
physics type question we do recommend
this
online textbook from this physics PhD
these presentations of course are all
available from the course homepage you
can download them and follow all the
links as Tina mentioned I can endorse
you any aero-astro majors who complain
that it's too hard remember that
everything that you're reading from the
FAA is designed for somebody who's still
in high school
Tina so this is just a sample question
they give you a flavor obviously we
haven't taught you the material yet but
why don't we just take a minute to read
this and then see if you guys can have a
good estimate as to the answer so I
thought this would be appropriate given
the weather conditions you guys had to
trudge through a lot of snow and slush
to get here today so here's a question
about Frost why is frost considered
hazardous to flight
okay who thinks it's a who thinks it's
be alright who thinks it's C alright
good job guys I mean just generally
icing bad for a plane so so anything
that's really increasing lift or
increasing control effectiveness that's
not what you're getting when you have
frost it's a bad thing so we'll discuss
this in more detail all right here's the
schedule for the next couple days we'll
just talk about the parts that are fun
this afternoon we're going to be visited
by an f-22 pilot that's a little better
than a Cessna Piper or Cirrus in terms
of performance if not in terms of
cost-effectiveness lunch time there's
going to be pizza and a slideshow about
Oshkosh the big aviation gathering that
happens in Wisconsin every year tomorrow
you're gonna hear from a designated
pilot examiner mark Nathanson who's an
aerobatic instructor and a US Air Force
f-4 fighter pilot veteran day three
Michael host Holdsworth is going to come
in he's a local drone pilot for
Hollywood so he'll tell you about using
the commercial drone license to do
something interesting at lunch on day
three on Thursday you're gonna hear from
a veteran actually know he's an active
duty officer in the Brazilian Air Force
who's here at MIT and he's going to tell
you about being a test pilot and then at
the end of the class we've tacked on the
founder of for flight which is one of
the most successful app aviation app
companies there in a lot of airline
cockpits now as a replacement for paper
and they do a lot of flight planning and
so he's gonna bring himself to talk
about you know any questions you might
have about starting the company
being successful in business and also
one of his engineering folks I think to
talk about the engineering behind the
app that's gonna be a little bit more
informal it's optional but we think
it'll be interesting okay so welcome
again and now you're part of the
community of aviators at least as soon
as you go on your first MIT flying club
fly out it is better to be on the ground
wishing you were in the air and then
vice versa but people have been wishing
to be in the air for tens of thousands
of years and we think that well we feel
lucky to be some of the few who are able
to control our own destiny through the
air so now it's time for questions while
you're formulating your brilliant
questions enjoyed these photos which I
snapped at the Reno Air Races where the
Blue Angels obviously already visited
what is the so yeah what why do you have
both AC power and DC power on a big jet
big jets the flight controls are too
heavy to be operated by a human so you
need a hydraulic power basically there
may still be steel cables going out to
the flight controls but they're just
modulating hydraulic pressure how do you
generate hydraulic pressure there's a
big motor to pump the hydraulics and
it's easier to run a big motor with AC
power compared to DC power so and the
engines are also spinning so if you just
think about Maxwell's equations it's
simple to run AC for that whereas the
electronics and also of course you can
have higher voltage and transform it
down and then for the electronics DC
power is what they want so that's why
the DC's in there to run radios and so
forth
you